so this is a sample of zinc and it's
very very high purity zinc so zinc again
is it's an abundant metal but it's a
metal that we all need for life it's
part of enzymes and it's part of many
many biologically mediated processes
think is a really soft metal sort of
grayish in color it reacts very easily
with acids to produce hydrogen in fact
it's the way that people make hydrogen
in the lamp or used to now they usually
buy it in cylinders so often zinc is
often found on things like rooves as
well very very high quality roofing
material very slow to oxidize zinc is
used very widely as a coating on iron so
called galvanizing you put a thin layer
of zinc and the zinc then corrodes
instead of the iron so that it stops the
an rusting at least for quite a long
time you can see it on corrugated iron
roofs I metal gates in the countryside
and so on and very often people put a
zinc washer around the bolt when they're
putting together metal things to try and
localize the corrosion and preventing it
zinc is quite important biologically and
there are all sorts of enzymes in our
bodies that use zinc and particularly
one called carbonic anhydrase that
catalyzes the reaction of co2 and water
and so without zinc none of us could
survive I don't know what else to say I
think it's a pretty boring metal really
is a boring metal